hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 34 hört zu und
spricht nach
ich packe den koffer ich packe den
koffer ich warte auf das taxi
ich warte auf das taxi
ich gebe das gepäck ab ich gebe das
gepäck ab ich treffe meine freundin
ich treffe meine freundin
wir wollen zusammen in die ferien
fliegen wir
zusammen in die ferien fliegen wir gehen
durch die kontrolle
wir gehen durch die kontrolle
wir warten auf das flugzeug
endlich können wir einsteigen
wir fliegen mit dem flugzeug nach
brasilien
wir sind gelandet
wir sind gelandet wir holen unser gepäck
ab wir holen unser gepäck ab wir nehmen
ein taxi wir nehmen ein taxi warst du
schon einmal in der türkei
warst du schon einmal in der türkei
ja ich war letztes jahr in der türkei in
istanbul
[Musik]
nein ich war noch nie in der türkei
ich bin
heute morgen ist es wechselhaft es gibt
wolken und die sonne schaut immer wieder
hervor
es bleibt aber den ganzen tag trocken
am abend ziehen dunkle wolken auf
am dienstag morgen scheint die sonne und
es wird warm
am nachmittag kann es gewitter geben und
stark regnen
am mittwoch beginnt der tag kalt und
eisig es wird schneien
es fällt ein halber meter schnee
achtung auf den straßen der starke
schneefall kann unfälle verursachen
warst du schon einmal in österreich
warst du schon einmal in österreich ja
ich war vor drei jahren in österreich in
wien
ja ich war vor drei jahren in österreich
in wien
nein ich war noch nie in österreich
ich hatte ein schönes wochenende
ich hatte schöne ferien
ich hatte spaß
wir waren letzten monat in den ferien
wir waren
letzten monat in den ferien letzten
monat waren wir in den ferien letzten
monat waren wir in den ferien
ich bin in die türkei geflogen
ich bin nach kolumbien geflogen
ich habe in einem hotel übernachtet
ich bin am strand gelegen
ich bin in den bergen gewandert ich bin
in den bergen gewandert ich bin zwei
wochen dort geblieben
ich bin zwei wochen dort geblieben
ich bin ein
monats dort geblieben ich bin einen
monat dort geblieben
ich habe jeden tag ausgeschlafen
ich bin jeden tag früh aufgestanden
ich habe in einem restaurant gegessen
ich habe
zu hause gegessen ich habe zu hause
gegessen
das wetter war
gut das wetter war gut
die sonne hat immer geschienen
die sonne hat immer geschienen das
wetter war schlecht das wetter war
schlecht
es hat oft geregnet
ich bin ski gefahren
es hat viel schnee gegeben
ich habe ein souvenir gekauft
ich habe ein museum besichtigt
bin ich ausgegangen am abend bin ich
ausgegangen
ich habe mich erholt
ich habe sehenswürdigkeiten besichtigt
[Musik]